[Music]
my entire life I've been practical I
make one romantic decision and it bit me
in the ass are you talking about work or
Gabrielle Harris
oh were you so shocked when they wrote
your bangs into the script for this
season I have changed my hair when I
felt like I've changed my life and it
felt like the perfect opportunity after
getting to know Emily season one and two
so much as who she was she's established
she can switch it up season three and
it's justifiable in the story I just
need to know are you on my team or not I
was beginning to wonder if you were
joining us at all I'm so in on team
whenever this company is called if you
had to work for one of these incredible
women who would it be Mindy would not
work for either of them what are you
talking about Mindy would be like let's
just make our own emotional company you
and Sylvie together oh my God I would
walk into that board room and I'd walk
straight out
we always talk about work-life balance
and right now I'm all about life
you know I love when the story starts
like that how do you think these two
very different characters help build
each other up and and what do they bring
out of each other she brings me back to
my core and allows me to sit and think
in silence and just know that my own
feelings and thoughts are enough of a
reason to justify making an action or a
decision I've had more and more of these
you know friendships but especially with
Lily of just oh my gosh I didn't even
realize my soul mate could be like a
friend as well you know I think that's
what we find in the story as and it's a
it's very special
[Music]